we're gonna sugar crash in about an hour
I know it's gonna be miserable mm-hmm
I'm okay with it
we're here today to try every donut on
the Dunkin Donuts menu literally here to
eat donuts every one of them in my mouth
except that I think now it's called
Dunkin
I'm a tried and true Dunkin Donuts girl
I grew up bringing munchkins to school
for people's birthdays you still bring
webkinz for people's birthday my
birthday was last week and she literally
brought in munchkins that's true
I eat doughnuts from anywhere I can get
them sell them on the street so I'm in a
vending machine I can order donuts on my
phone now yeah we've done that bring it
on
yeah let's do this this one is the
toasted coconut doughnut smells like a
Samoa oh good its fluffy - it tastes
like delicious sugar coconut on cake in
my mouth it's really good if I were on
vacation and I wanted a doughnut
this would be it I just need this every
day so it's like I'm on vacation I guess
that works too I've never seen a square
doughnut before I wish there were more
cookie crumbles on the top oh okay wait
mind I ain't good there's chocolate
inside of this doughnut oh these are
definitely not pendants on the top you
know I know what that's like and not
this it's a yes for me she likes it not
a meant fan but I'll eat this stuff in
the middle every day when I picture a
doughnut from Dunkin Donuts it's this
bad boy right here
this is classic doughnut for you you
expect a bit of like a snap with these
sprinkles and they're like soft they're
soft the doughnut icing - donut bread
break a streak ratio is completely off
if this isn't drizzling down the sides
then we
problem I'll heat it up for I am NOT
gonna order it at the donut shop I got
the beautiful little bunt I got right
the runt of the litter that's not good
oh my god and it's actually raw inside
yeah mine's raw too so that could also
be why we are not enjoying this to the
fullest just dripping yeah it's really
oily I wouldn't eat this for sure even
up where I am
first impressions bullring it's all the
same color so you're looking at this
doughnut and you're like I don't know
what's on it it is a little hard on top
you hear that oh it's not bad it smells
I feel like there are far superior
doughnuts at Dunkin Donuts that I'm not
gonna waste my time on this one again
oh the frosting to pastry ratio is
unacceptable
I'm gonna try it oh okay yeah take it in
there it tastes exactly how I thought it
was gonna taste I don't hate it but I
also don't love it I think that does
donut on the inside is cooked perfectly
though a little fluffy a little cakey
strawberry donut good in my book I'll
give it a thumb bring it on oh I know
what this is
you know when the chocolate cream
doughnut the go-to doughnut of my youth
probably one of the highest calorie
Donuts on the menu however if you are a
chocolate lover this is it very messy to
eat in the car high school me got this
all over her car and actually adult me
gets it all over her car - I feel like
you're describing an old relationship oh
my god I love this the cake itself
oh it's not so much about the cake we're
gonna drivers live it so I feel like
it's really dense and
like hiding this delicious little yeah
nugget I would order the donut to eat
the chocolate out of the middle but I
ate all the only the frosting out of
them and I literally I mean in the
frosting I don't know
another maple one I hope not okay let's
wedding try this one I hate it
this one's like way too sugary it is the
exact same as the round donut from
earlier except this one's a long log
shape and it tastes worse
there's a reason Donuts our donut shaped
and this is just a block of pastry no
I'm not okay with this one this is the
blueberry probably glazed donut did I
flirt that yep you're on a donut high
right now I am the glaze seems like it's
not caked on it it seems like it's been
like gradually drizzled just like a
buffoon that one isn't good this is like
one of my top ones today no I'm not even
going back I don't want it nice I know
it's a little bit better and at least
it's shaped better and it's cold in this
one listen I'm not wasting my I'm not
saying that these are little hairs cuz
they're not but this pastry dough hasn't
formed little hairlike structures I mix
the unbaked it doe egg but I'm not gonna
finish this yeah this one I know no to
me dog double no for me oh this one
looks reminiscent I have to be honest
I've never had this one because the
chocolate was so good not as good at all
of it look that felt like taking sugar
with a spoon yes and licking it like a
lollipop maybe if I wouldn't have had
ten Donuts already I could have handled
it like a bad marshmallow fluff and let
me tell you what it's not that
yeah don't let this one we're now trying
the chocolate cake donut I'm assuming
it's the chocolate donut all the
frosting it's soft you can tell it was
like made today when it's perfect
the donut is 100% on point mm-hmm
glaze delicious okay cake is pernicious
right I would prefer a little bit more
glaze
whoever glazes this worming was a little
lazy I'm not giving this back to you I'm
gonna save it for later
Mike the oval double double as happy as
I was with the last cake donut mm-hmm
this one's gonna be even better because
it's dipped in chocolate this glaze is
coming off on my finger so that might be
a little too sugary but in all I'm
excited for this one mmm chocolate
lovers I like this I would suggest this
one highly chocolate on chocolate we're
changing now if you're cheating this
would be one of the ones that I've
purchased when I go to yeah oh this
looks like the kind of donuts that my
grandma used to make me this one looks
like someone sat on it okay well you
can't even wait for me we didn't even
introduce it you made it I'm gonna pass
this is two thumbs down refer me but
really this wasn't a great doughnut this
one I feel like is the same doughnut but
glaze instead of sugared and I'm not
gonna lie to you not the biggest fan of
glazed regular donut it's for the plain
Jane's of the world nothing wrong with
it if I'm gonna go into a donut shop I'm
gonna get it don't a fancy donut I'm
gonna get something that's a little more
kick to it these are the fluid and
powdered Donuts that you buy in the
package that are delicious why would you
go to a donut store and buy I know cuz I
guarantee you it's not gonna be as good
as the ones that I get at the gas
station make it rain thank you it's very
hard actually yeah do you want to try it
no but I will for the people okay it
tastes exactly like the ones from the
pouch
mmm it's not worth it I think that's
good I approve of these because I'm a
fan of the little donut space just like
them hard pass
lemon filled mmm don't know what you're
saying don't eat it by itself
don't eat the filling on its own squeeze
it out it's all a minute I can't pick up
lemon lovers will be all over this
I feel better right now I'm telling
myself I'm eating fruit overall it's
fine I don't think I'm a fan of powdered
sugar on a doughnut it's like I already
know the sugar in it and they're gonna
put sugar on it on the outside what's
the point
oh yeah I know what this one is what is
this one some kind of berries filled we
know Hubbard because we can see the
whole is a raspberry raspberry this is
one of my tops I appreciate that they
put actual sugar on this one and not the
powdered sugar because I feel like it
sticks to the donut better this one to
me seems like the whole package okay
ready 1 2 3 oh [ __ ] [ __ ] custard is
great yeah put it in everything get this
powdered sugar off my frigging don't go
away I'm done with him but it's not
because I've had 10 of them today that's
because I've had 10 of them today bring
on the last donut bring it on
grand finale it better be good I can get
on board with this as being our last one
because it combines all of the stuff
that we've seen today chocolate top
chocolate frosting we've got the classic
regular donut and then inside I'm
assuming as my delicious custard so this
is the perfect donut she the one look at
this cross section right here chocolate
check custard check donut better cake
chairman yeah this is definitely one of
my top dog I mean it's classic it's
probably all over my face that's yeah
that's just great I had some real
winners yes real losers
least favorite would have to be roller
it was wrong on all types of levels that
one was my least favorite as well this
Jona this one right here this laughs
gotta be the winner this one was my
favorite
this is the chocolate cake one that I
have here with me yeah I'm the crew I
forgot about this one this one was the
best one this is number one flow second
I don't suggest eating them all at once
don't do that but grab 1211 glazed in
one special one get the glaze once to
your friends and you eat the good one
yeah
[Music]